هناك ست مبادئ وعامه تطلب الدول المشاركه
في مقاطعه قطر من الدوحه التوقيع عليها
وتشمل عناوين عريضه حول محاربه الارهاب
والتطرف هل يمكن ان تكون قطر على استعداد
للتوقيع عليها وانهاء ما
يحصل دوله قطر اظهرت منذ البدايه مواقف
بناءه تجاه حل الازمه وطلبنا عده مرات عقد
اجتماعات للجلوس معا وعرض الادله الموجوده
الان الامر بات بي الدول المشاركه بالحصار
والتي عليها ان تقرر وتجلس ال
الطاوله ما مدى الضرر الذي تعرض له اقتصاد
قطر هناك بالتاكيد المعانه التي شهدتها
الخطوط الجويه القطريه واضطرارها لتغيير
مسار رحلاتها الى جانب اضطرارك لاستيراد
ماكولات من تركيا وايران فما مدى الضرر
الذي تعتقد انه
حصل اؤكد لك ان اقتصادنا لم يتضرر قطر صلب
وقوي ونحن مرتاحون ويمكننا الاستمرار على
الوضع الحالي الى الابد لكن حكومتنا تتطلع
الى حل هذه الازمه بسرعه لاننا نؤمن انها
ازمه مضره بالجميع وخاصه بجهود الحرب على
الارهاب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ريك
تيلرسون زار قطر ووقع اتفاقيه حول محاربه
الارهاب وزار السعوديه ايضا لكن هل كان
الامر يستحق ذلك هل من نتيجه او
تقدم علينا ان نتعامل مع هذه القضيه بشكل
مختلف الاتفاقيه الموقعه مع قطر تتعلق
بدعم جهود امريكا لمحاربه الارهاب وهذا هو
فحواها اما بالنسبه للقضايا المرتبطه
بالازمه الحاليه فانا اؤمن بان موقفنا
واضح للغايه وقد جاء على لسان وزير
خارجيتنا عندما قال اننا دوله عقلانيه
ونحن ننخرط في جميع الجهود بشكل بناء
السؤال هنا هل سائر الدول تتعامل بشكل
بناء ايضا هذه هي الاسئله التي تحتاج
للاجابه
عليها هل تشعر حكومتكم بان الطرف الاخر
وخاصه السعوديه تريد التوصل الى حل لانهاء
الازمه ام ان هناك امورا اكبر تتعلق
بالنفوذ او قضايا كتلك التي قلتم انها
تتعارض مع
سيادتكم اظن انه من مصلحه الجميع الوصول
الى حل للازمه لان الوضع القائم ليس مفيدا
لاحد اؤمن ان قطر اظهرت جديه في البحث عن
حل ونريد ان نرى ان دولا اخرى جديه كذلك
في ايجاد الحلول